today the attempt will be to set the  fastest speed ever accomplished in an  aircraft that originally was made in  World War two it's a good question and  why would you want to do something like  this and honestly there's no good  explanation you know there's no money  involved in it I'm sure none of you have  ever heard about this record  this is 1940s technology the engine is  commonly breaking today we're squeezing  every last minute of your traveling at  800 feet per second which is faster than  a 45 caliber bullet out of the puzzle  you have an engine that is screaming  aloud in front of you the cockpits 140  degrees inside there's no computers no  digital touchscreens  you talk to the engine console it caress  it come on hold together you can hold  together  to break this record you have to be  perfect